[Music]
i guess we could do this this is one
that i this is fresh
so we finally did actually get joe rogan
talking about bobby lee okay
we are we all you'll see
um
so uh this is uh again from two buttons
like i said they they clip a lot of the
stuff so just so you know where it's
from
uh but check this out before i'm a huge
fan of bobby lee he should be on his
podcast i love bobby i saw he was on
your show yeah he's i is by the way he's
been invited to my podcast multiple
times okay multiple times well you
should you should get him on i'm gonna
have to reach out to him yeah i feel
like i believe rogan in that bobby lee
probably has been invited a bunch of
times i also think bobby lee doesn't
want to fly to texas
he is so even when he was in california
he probably had invites but i just think
probably he's kind of an agoraphobic
creep yeah
oh i might have to fly to l.a and hold
his hand and drag him out of here i
think he just needs a real invitation he
knows i love him i cry because there's
been a lot of drama lately and one of
the things that
gotta love rogan's politics huh
look there's been a lot of drama all
right there's been a lot of
consummate politician this guy huh what
happened was somehow another my name got
entered into this thing and
some okay see now i can turn now you
turn
somehow your name got entered into this
thing
somehow the king's name got brought up
in his own kingdom yeah somehow somehow
joe it's not somehow your name got
brought up
you're the reason all of this happened
yes and i don't think it was on purpose
i don't think like i don't think it was
malicious this is like joe biden
discussing baby formula shortages and
being like yeah somehow my name keeps
getting brought up yeah you're the
president look put it to you this week
it's very simple if you want to if you
want to look at this how it is if you
didn't encourage brendan shaw to be a
comic and use your sway to help get him
a showtime special he wouldn't have the
balls to hit on other people's
girlfriends yes
and then make fake claims about reddit
so somehow joe rogan
wants to be a king
but he doesn't want anybody to
say well i do control these people
would you not respect joe a little bit
more if he goes look i know i have sway
in the la comic community you know but
not everything that happens i could be
blamed you know what i mean but like but
this whole like
my name little old 200 million dollar a
year spotify account me
me
really i've had presidential candidates
on my show little old me
i'm against gun control unless bernie
sanders is in the room
that's true we're taking all of them
away
every single gun oh wow that's wow
that's interesting i love that yeah like
i've already got every single gun oh wow
okay cool yeah you know guns you know
how do people donate
exactly
old the shape of whatever he's pulled
into joe rogan
and i don't even hate joke because i
picked you here i don't need joe rogan
joe rogan sometimes says things that are
pretty smart and i agree with him and
joe rogan sometimes says things that is
stinky
and somehow the new studio design just
fly off just go fly off the wall man he
really did not like the people called
his initial new studio before he changed
it back to the old look a [ __ ]
toaster oven huh toaster oven tanning
bed
and he just changed it without
mentioning it nope
i don't want to get into it in too much
detail but why joe
don't worry
we will
i'm like okay i must call bobby and i
called him and i said listen i don't
know what kind of i'm just well i had
his assistant call him my assistant
called him but yeah just my assistant
called his girlfriend
hey jamie do me a favor call bobby lee
for me
thanks
come on come on i'm busy
no rogan's one of those guys that has
you call him and then you have to wait
for him to come on the phone yeah
i've got joe for you
i must call bobby and i called him and i
said listen i don't know what kind of
i'm just hearing about this nonsense now
but i love you i would never let anybody
talk bad about you i would never let
anybody come on my show and talk bad
about you
okay
i think you're an awesome guy i think
you're incredibly talented and i know
that you have here's what i think i do
not i do honestly
tell me what you think marsh but because
we will never really know but
i really don't think joe rogan in any
way was involved in any of this reddit
drama and brandon shaw i think he
doesn't even know right no of course not
i think he's dude he's [ __ ] joe rogan
right like what do you mean he doesn't
know about any of this right i do think
that somebody
probably brian cowan
but we don't know for sure but this is
just my guess with all the information
we've pieced together
did bring up rogan's name to bobby lee
right without rogan talking to rogan
probably what i was like hey yeah you
know what i'll talk to rogan too if this
is true i'll go on his show and i'll f
you know i'm sure
somebody said that to him right
yeah that's that kind of
because it checks out we've heard the
rogan name being thrown around bobby lee
mentioned it when he was on ethan
klein's show
about you know then they started
bringing a brogan and you know a fear
of like performing and putting out a
special and stuff like that but i really
think you should because i think you're
one of the best comedians alive and i
think and i've said that to him
let's
look i like bobby lee okay
but
rogan have you not learned from over
complimenting people what you get is
gringo poppy
you have to have learned that by now
bobby lee is funny bobby lee is a
billion times funnier than brendan chob
i've never said bobby lee wasn't funny
bobby lee is a funny guy if you don't
believe me even watch his early mad tv
stuff the guy's a funny dude
you know depending when he plays the
right character he's a really funny guy
yeah but
that being said he's not one of the
funniest comedians around okay
he he's not [ __ ] louis ck he's not
ricky gervais or dave chappelle all
right those are like the funniest
comedians around right now
many many times he knows i love him i
cry because there's been a lot of drama
lately and one of the things that
happened was somehow another my name got
entered into this thing and i don't want
to get into it in too much detail but he
just clicked that second i must call
bobby so what do you think how much do
you think rogan knew i have to ask i'm
really wondering
how much do you think
rogan actually knew
when do you think he was looped in
because this clip is from like yesterday
i think i would guess
at the point right after h3
if i had to guess okay i think the h3
thing was when it was like
but he still probably kept his mouth
shut he probably did the whole thing we
said he did which is probably calling
people and going fix this h
gotta fall on the sword but somebody fix
this you know what you're you're you're
actually right though that's a really
good point
because h3 as much as i hate him is is a
big enough show where
it's not like it where rogan's gonna
hear about it right because trust me h3
has said some pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
things about rogan
would you look there's certain things
you could i think it's perfectly good
criticisms of rogan but h3 was like yeah
you know joe rogan being unhealthy is
going to get people killed if they don't
get vaccinated and then somebody put the
side by side of what rogan looks like
versus what ethan clinton is like now
and you're like bro shut up all right
shut the [ __ ] up all right you could say
a lot a lot of things about rogan but
rogan knows nutrition and [ __ ] right
like this guy [ __ ] runs a mile a day
every [ __ ] day so yeah i don't think
he yeah dude [ __ ] ethan's blowing up
even more since then
yeah yeah he's got well you saw him in
the bobby lee thing
um
okay so i also have this i haven't
listened to pre-listen to this one yet
michael bisping yes yes ufc's michael
bisping
former louis j gomez co-host that's
correct uh reacts to the brandon shop
gringo poppy bobby lee drama she want to
hear this one
yes
okay and it's the best mma show out
there so tell me how hard did you laugh
at gringo puppy
how did you well first of all how hard
did you laugh at gringo pappy i didn't
laugh per se
i chuckled
didn't laugh per se now what you see
happening here is he's being nice right
because you know they're kind of friends
but
i don't mind if you're being nice and
also being honest right
like at least he's being honest right
okay let's
let's go back here
oh
i laughed to myself inside there was a
couple of jokes like you know
mexican cookies
he's trying so hard are you not cringing
as hard as i am right now with this
because i am cringing [ __ ] hard he's
trying so hard
okay i'm gonna press play again
mexican cookies
are chocolate chips with salsa on it's
hilarious there was some stuff but i'm
just not
it sounds like did that sound like he
was making fun of him the way he said
that
yeah that's you know mexican cookies are
hilarious
he sounds more like somebody who's like
his his representative or his manager
just trying to spin
yeah i i know he's being nice i i get
that he's trying
but this is not coming across the way he
thinks it's coming across
and to be fair you know brendan shaw
becoming a comedian is like michael
bisping becoming a comedian you know
like
michael bisping does great when when
michael bisping talks about like ufc and
stuff i think he's actually really good
you know
i'm just not a luller i'm not a laugh
out tight louder
you're not a laugh you know
what i'm not a lullaby you're famous for
your laugh i'm not famous for my life
i'm famous for being ultra smart
um
all right are you aware that bobby and
brendan sharp situation if so are my
team bobby
i don't want to talk about tittle tattle
but i am on both levels
yes i saw it seems a little weird i like
bobby lee i like him a lot i like
brendan sharp nothing against the guy
but
it feels like bobby's got more of a
higher standing on that one
oh boy
very diplomatic answers man even
even another like ufc guy that you know
ufc dude one of his boys usc boys is
like
yeah no i prefer the little asian man
yeah this is not great i prefer the
little asian man with no testosterone i
pick him
i would say the walls are closing in on
brendan's shot but he's too stupid to be
able to tell yeah he doesn't know what
walls are he doesn't know he has hero he
already has narrowed vision from all the
brain punches
brenda's been hit so many times he only
seasoned four by three
brendan has the peripheral the
peripheral vision of tan crenshaw
you can only see one side yeah seriously
but seriously and that's and that eye is
focused on brian callan but seriously
sawsan cookies right
dude it's pretty good like mexican
cookies
how did you well first of all how hard
did you laugh at gringo puppy i didn't
laugh per se
ouch
so he's you know i think brennan shops
doing great
he can't just keep doing comedy right
i love what he even she called the man
he's like look i'm not a big lawler and
i'd be lollers what he was saying he was
like he's like no you're like famous for
your laugh and he's like shut up
you love comedy you always tell me how
much you just laugh laugh and laugh when
you go to these places
and just just like i've seen you do
shows with louis j gomez you laughed all
the time yeah seriously well well here's
why though and hear me out and i don't
know if you thought of this just because
lucia gomez is funny
it's probably
is a factor how about this who is the
worst group of fans
oh they all can be pretty mean to your
boy
uh
there's there's nothing worse than a
salty comic who didn't make it
especially with on the internet because
hey they're comics so they'll be pretty
witty at writing so the burns are going
to hurt let's be creative
like i'll get out a failed comic who
didn't mean did people wonder why p he
not people wonder he wonders why people
don't like him
yeah this might be why people don't like
you
you're a failed comic you know what you
are you're a failed comic who made it
because even worse of your friends you
didn't earn [ __ ]
i didn't rick [ __ ] oh you're you're fat
or you're stupid all right whatever dude
but the comic will really rosham he's
talking about us marsh
no but they just never made it and
you're doing pretty well there's nothing
worse than a salty comic who hasn't made
it and if you're a guy who's newer to
comedy they are
toned
but if you're a guy that's doing the
comedy those guys aren't usually mean to
new comics because they know that what
it's like you know making it in the
business and being working hard
they're making fun of you because
they're [ __ ] i'm funnier than you
because you're parking a [ __ ] 100 000
truck on the sidewalk of the comedy
store exactly and then trying to get
everybody to suck your dick
allegedly your comedian friends
wives dick
they will hurt your feelings and that's
why i want to talk to you about therapy
because it's helped me out man
has it
has it you look like you're doing really
good you have you you're looking you're
looking you have bobby lee up like he's
pepe silva
right now
on your wall trying to figure out who's
the hacker
and then of course the hacker known as
bobby lee and then this
that's what it take to overwhelm and
kill you in a fight kind of like a new
york rat san francisco rat and like a
calabasas rat it would be some hours
because eventually i'd like
eventual
and ct software or
you're my hot ferrari can you stop being
a dick he has brain damage
profound brain damage
good cardio so it's gonna be a fight
i'll give myself i in my life is on the
line i would give myself around 24 hours
many rats will it take to kill you
brendan schwab 24 hours four hours okay
we gotta hear that again because it's
hard to understand him because of the
brain but
how many rats would it take to kill
that's what it take to overwhelm and
kill you in a fight kind of like a new
york rat san francisco rat and like a
calabasas rat it would be some hours
because the venture i'd like
and then [ __ ] you know i have good
cardio so it's gonna be a fight i'll
give myself i in my life is on the line
i would give myself around 24 hours
okay yeah so i just want to make sure 24
hours worth of rats
that makes sense maybe sorry does he
measure time in rats
like
hey man i'll be there in like 16 rats
okay
listen man give me like 20 rats
with traffic maybe 30 reps maybe 30 rats
oh are you stupid
oh stupid brad stupid dumb dumb brad
i'll give myself i in my life is on the
line i would give myself around 24 hours
but two buttons again i gotta say he's
the one clipping all this stuff in case
you're looking for these without our
stupid voices do you think brandon likes
him i'm a super do you think brendan's
lawyers know about
him probably